autism be a rapper so bad can tell
you've been heavily criticized in the
past and it's bothering nutrifreeze I'd
rather just naive and talk about any
respondents ever bad for some reason
people just really care about it what
did you learn from that experience
generally don't get stabbed yes
yeah you talk about like some of these
shows where people would like a lot of
gunshots in the air and [__] sometimes
we've been there people have been
murdered everything around it opened my
eyes to like a world that was always
there but I didn't really know that much
about
[Music]
I'm gonna [__] kill you I said one
day you're gonna push me through fire
and win a cool bomb are you so you're
familiar with care science stuff like
that yeah from from when you've got a
record deal what the [__] is it took me
to kiss the whole game was ya thinking
people watching people play games
actually his new record on point is
actually like the best youtuber song I
think that's been made so far like you
got angry like yeah like on YouTube rap
because these guys like entertainers and
stuff you can't hold them to the same
standards as a perfect like a person who
just wraps all day every day they're
making videos with fighters they doing
all sorts of [__] but that was a hell of
a song I actually like that
yeah he's whole everything he's doing I
just got that so much respect for him
I'll just just the boxing gave me more
respect for it yeah because why not
really started going in that and
training them all that a lot of risk to
keep you out of trouble or like see him
he got a shitload of money basically he
died well got did really well he could
have just messed around yeah drinking
and smoking weed all day or going with
what I would have done to be like that's
what I'm trying to explain the like
because I talked to some pro fight has
not interviewed like a UFC fighters and
I was like he doesn't have to get in and
fight for anything like any still doing
it like to me that's almost as equally
as commendable because he's got a lot
more alone he's starting with a lot of
loose well you've got nothing to lose
that's not spot cleaner and he's like
the cocky arrogant funny youtuber like
his his brand is changed forever then he
can't be like miss I don't feel like
anyone see him as last time sort of hard
man where admire anyway I use bit cocky
people probably enjoy seeing him getting
knocked at anything to come back right
off your lack he'd have lat
it feels like a rapper was gonna like in
his top so a call
would you say yes like if you know like
I've sparred with some rappers yeah like
in the finger just that but that always
what was that like EPO did you suppose
the best spa he's a best fastball spar
deliver temper T once here you'll be
surprised that in your boxers couldn't
say how many rappers couldn't I know
obviously Bugsy Malone he can he can box
yeah he sparred with fair care side look
quite even I reckon it I reckon me was
like we probably hasn't been in his
training as much by if it came down to
huffing like you reckon he was holding
back a little bit laughing hotties from
the roads like if he wanted to really
but I think he's got manners I've met
him my fees got a lot of manners who
else um thing he could use the box um 50
cent was a boxer before really yeah okay
with John from here um Meridian done
raining looks like a boxer as well he's
got that kind of face yeah are we
rolling everyone are we going anyway
yeah but I respect the discipline
because that's why I love boxing that's
why I love me in our box the discipline
I mean so for K aside to do that and put
himself rude at that's not that that's a
lot obviously not to the same standard
as they embody but just and it's very
entertaining gold the top boxes involve
the Nike Davi he's a wicked role model
for kids I agree cuz he's got kids
boxers were having a Gore about this
saying like some I think some of them
were a bit like I guess if you work your
ass off to get in the position another
20,000 arena yeah and these kids go
second fight all right Serena MIT they
did like 800,000 buys which is more than
most UFC's or it's a little bit it was
cheaper than the UFC but still the
points made yeah it hoofed a few of them
but I think boxing hasn't been getting
that young audience for years like UFC
is dominated that and it's like they
actually getting more kids involved in
boxing than any boxing even Anthony
Joshua I think you've also I think the
industry sort of realized what they were
doing wrong was who they were appealing
to with some of the wrong people in
boxing like they the money
like KITT there are so much money but
you can tell some of the boxers who got
outraged about it just want eyes on them
and the attention rather than adulation
in the ring but they dare any decent
level box I've and I know these amateurs
the training they put themselves for
audio so if you see someone comedy plays
computer games for a living and come in
and you can fill up that big arenas and
is gonna use this stuff when so will you
a record deal yeah understand why no oh
the audience is there look oh the
world's changed I'll [__] alright let me
just get with the world in cuz that's
was it that way is it's adapt or die
exactly in anything so they're just just
like now like you've got this this is
this hole it was out there back in the
day I'd been going on some talk show us
I yeah it's a lot more we're bigger than
TV in that right yes that's the spirit
this is the new Graham not bak Jonathan
Ross right
j-dog and you have actually but nah I'm
a fan yeah because I'm looking at him
lat why is he I'm trying to think of a
lot another entrepreneurial kind of
mogul entertainer to come from the past
so kind of compare him to that's how I'm
looking at him as an inspiration it's
mad life it feels like we're seeing
youtubers know like it's a lot like the
music game like when people like jay-z
came out and all of a sudden Rockaway
happen and all these are the things that
branch it out like youtubers are doing
the same thing they're getting their own
clothes and lanes they're just
everything it's like a tree it's just a
box it was that with music fair enough
lack because everyone what everyone but
loads of people want a rap and is
looking to do with career I never saw
the box infinite come in I never saw
that coming
and then to make it and it and I like it
because they just got those to show
anyone if you put the training in could
do that do some decent boxing you learn
to flat for me it's interesting as well
because a lot of people didn't think
about how many people get interested in
boxing and then suddenly get into the
mainstream part of it and it's the same
for when he started
and stuff I imagine there are loaded
teenagers who are like I never thought
I'd listen to that but now k sized in
and then they'll get into it because
they're suggested songs down the side
from people like you
yeah obviously if you feel like you're
the guy that you might have a problem
with you what it that's your problem
dude this is what the world is now
that's it
so actually I'm we started the podcast
yeah yeah when you start a podcast like
it's all one good have an interesting
interviews but in an ideal world you
want to have the people you grew up
listening to so your second best Ergon
Dizzee Rascal 101 true geordie podcast
Dizzee Rascal this is a dream it is
because I think you've already told this
story to you about when you went to
sponsor 15 years ago just after boy in
the corner dropped you on and your first
tour and you and all the you knees and
that you can castle uni and front row
screaming me how I was there
that's ran into the point where Jezebel
gonorrhea herpes no and you got main
island I wish there was more phones out
oh yeah them times there because think
of how much I was doesn't know that you
know I all went home I was like I didn't
like it aligned with Dizzee Rascal that
was my first ever gig that ever went it
reads you I think that's the first time
I've ever been to new course as well was
it always under yeah if at all I reckon
I've done must be at least eight shows
in over the years now my memory of that
is like crystal clear like I remember
the smoke comes out you've got your hood
on and you come out and there did
sitting here and like there was like you
did the whole album did I come at that
I've come at sitting on your chair sort
of thing and the audience because being
a short since I'm like where it's a huge
arena but that was so in close and
personal
that was the best for that reason
because it felt like you were like in
the crowd practically yeah do you ever
miss doing like Shores like that I know
the money's [__] great when you do
those huge arenas but it's a different
feeling I would imagine doing that no
it's cool because it's all about the
energy you could have a massive crowd
and if they're not moving the way you
want him to yeah then thousand people
got mad is just as good yeah yeah but
boy in the corner for me it was like the
soundtrack of my teenagers and I know
you've probably had this a fuckton but
like your frustration in the aldman like
how you were feeling you just nailed it
like you captured what everyone was
thinking at that age group like at that
time and like you you were to me it was
like I've been listening to 50 cent came
out not long before that and you were
like in hard to that like not really
yeah really like jay-z NAS Tupac all and
all of them but we didn't have our guy
and like you were the guy the first
first one and like that album was like
you reminded it was it was our Illmatic
I felt like it was like that sort of
that's crazy that's all it's mad to hear
a few people say not over the years but
cuz I was so in the middle of it yeah
and then like saying I went for him
whatever doing pirate radio to that
album coming out winning the Mercury's
do not really understand what's going on
yeah and then jump into doing tours and
then travelling going to France all
around America around into Europe and
then sit there and do that got 13
interviews to do but they and saying the
same [__] so that's what my life became
so I never got to feel it like everyone
else did yeah did that experience not
pass you by and then now you only sort
of realizing it now no way and then I
dropped straight into the second one
yeah I dug in him oh very yeah you did
you have that music ready to go or were
people like let's get another album out
quick
no I was on it I've always been lad I've
never been one to be told to jump in the
studio right just let now I've just put
this got this EP bit jumped in myself
you seem like one of those rappers who
can belt a song after you've had a [__]
like you know I mean like yeah sometimes
that is it don't always happen for your
hurt but when it happens it's bless its
place but just try to stay in the studio
but boy in the corner was like it had so
many different levels to it like there
was conscious songs and then there was
like song as you play in a club like you
cover everything and I think that that
was why it blew people away because it
wasn't missing anything but I was into
all the old albums you talked about yeah
I was inside I came up well being a fan
of the album format so 2pac albums nice
in Mars albums with jay-z ours I
listened to all those hours it seemed
like a lot of story tell because that's
what I was I'm the biggest TV program
yes all just like that's why you got
that bit that angst or just just web
that's be a bit of soulfulness or just
that the anger and all day and like
craft to puck like that like that
feeling like when he was really really
around the corner
yeah and how long were they warned me oh
yeah shed so many tears yeah it was a
real storytelling those were my songs
were are related to you more SEC brand
new day and stuff and do it like I was
like listen like is if you were talking
right into my head like on the
headphones when I'm walking around
I've had some mad little scenarios where
lack we're just we're showing me how
much it's meant to some people like this
and I told you son everybody told stone
I was in Manchester once I think I went
there I was a few free free of my
friends but we went there for
Westwood was doing pimp my ride then Wow
can we get an impression of that just
now when you came in here jog your ride
was whack and I don't mean in a good way
that's my famous clothes right
find a duvet and John Lewis not long ago
right genuinely I did this yes it was a
wig I you know when you see someone
doing something normal and you're like
oh my god I love you from so many
different things cause and then you go
you buying a duvet sir see Westwood pin
my right so we had a party in Manchester
so Lou in there yeah and I was in their
future I feel bubble footsie Marvin
there's war and a bunch of our people so
slightly put us in the VIP and I was
with Debbie colder as well me with
Debbie Debbie at the time she's don't do
what we Sol solid manage sauce and she
ended up in Miami working with Busta
Rhymes and violin a record snow she was
really you know as well and then um I
start this big security dude massive who
actually was westwoods at one point as
well so something I were in a VIP and in
his I'm seeing some bit of commotion and
like what's going on here I've seen
these these couple where they went they
had to probably be in a bit of my age or
a little bit younger just like mix rates
do you know that way and he's just not
having it he's security this is his time
to shine
he's not having it and the other
security to tau he's left several full
dude lat and then they are not having
Eva so I'm like what is happening here
and then I've seen one of them pushing
the garner finger at him and that's
enough love I said I so Connor - yeah
yeah I just remember would have come
come come come sit down I feel I feel
like that's what all that day all they
wanted sit ups at their desks at down me
like cool cool cool cool just sometimes
with them like security sometimes they
can get in the way and for dealing with
Street Street guys sometimes easy just
just chapter him just squash it
so I'm not what's going on one of them
was called the other one was just trying
to have a bit yeah I see you you've got
your chain yeah yeah you've got your
traps you've got your chain so what's
your point now were you saying yeah I'm
just saying it I'm just saying whatever
that's my Manchester accent yeah it's
pretty
perfect yeah so bla bla bla truth and
then um then eventually the other one is
kind of just started port lat
started getting emotional starts of
Allah I remember I used to wake up every
morning we were nine in me and singing
past me swung past me green blast out
plus that's a lot pass out I'm lame and
they just start making music for the
white people this guy's lat rah so all
this the lat really you just wanted to
just show me that like it's all love mmm
like he just just that's how much he
cared but it was almost a situation so
wherever we smooth that up it's cool
they go it's not to lack of the next
thing a couple days aside I found that
so when they come in they wasn't on
their own so there was they look with a
bunch of older people so there's almost
like a setup said they've come and the
bouncers are telling they can't and then
one about when a day older people
woman's told them right let them sort it
out let them sort it out and it was like
nah that ID card well and he said ah he
didn't listen and he got knocked out
well so whoever's with them not a boxer
at all nah I'm not even seeing none of
this this is a this is what's happening
before they just got there so that's how
deep it was that's how much just that's
not my point is that's how much the
music means to people in it is land just
they were ready to knock people out
people gonna get really hurt just if
someone could get near me yeah to tell
me that that had been listening to me
for since then it's a bag of situations
were not being like in a club whatever
and guys have condoms it's about your
when I was in charge it got me free
child I've had a lot of that as well
that album wearing a Hornets mission you
know yeah it was like a feeling of like
I don't know if it was what you're
trying to put across but the way I pick
the dopers ayat hopelessness like it was
frustration and like yeah no one is
gonna [__] listen chin and I mean
it's also the surprise of having someone
so young sort of saying those sort of
things as well I think it the fact that
a lot of people weren't used to hearing
someone how that clarify you a good when
that was written off that 1718 which is
like in intelligence as they off the
charts for that age right but that comes
from that that sort of but me but maybe
more people are intelligent at that age
and people just don't know is it as well
I want to rape myself obviously if I
clap maybe you never listen to the
average it you know you might get a lot
more out of them than all the people
would actually give them the product
what I'm saying I'm not necessarily
taking away from anyone else I just
think it surprised people at that time
then you that sense of clarity the fact
you could put something which had like
such a completeness to it I think and I
made the beasts as well exactly yourself
most of you yeah yeah I'm looking meant
or not because I actually think that
musically I prefer boy in the corner to
possibly short time which you probably
had a lot more money to play around with
for the bits I would imagine like no I
was the same I was using the same
literally well how do you make what did
you make those times it was just uh it's
just logic a bunch of samples laid out
in the keyboards it's wicked because I
see Timbaland say the same thing that's
how we used to do really he's getting
used to learn you didn't learn to use
the MPC same as myself right when he got
put in front me I couldn't do it it
looks fun though doesn't it it's hard
yeah I've tried it no I couldn't do it
but I just laid a finger out in front of
me not put a bunch of see it's easy in
it so that's what I was using by day and
it was made on the same thing literally
right when I say back to back I came
back from Napa and I made know the first
song I've recorded was a respect me
wonder made that beat that didn't come
out until the second album note that it
didn't really sound that on shore time
isn't it
but but I made it before when the corner
came ah
didn't you me after you got disturbed
that's the first thing I came back got
healed a bit and I was literally in the
booth stools and I taking my stitches
out but I've taken him out but I was
still worth still quite fresh do we need
to rewind didn't explain that yeah I'm
sure you've probably explained this a
[__] million times but like the mount
I mean I don't have you seen Twitter but
like the amount of questions I've had
for you I [__] insane so alright so
the stubborn happened how long after you
made release boy in the corner why did
you release the it was already done
right I shouldn't have been in line
apart I should have been in England for
my album launch
for the launch now some persuaded me
that we should go to Napa because the
booking money was good cuz when I come
around despite what people wouldn't like
to think that everything went up cuz I
had my own buzz as well as being with
interviews were even even Wiley said
like you were the superstar and everyone
wanted to sort of write your Coretta so
that's why we need to go to Napa with
you and I went because at the time I
didn't know when album launch by it was
dumb as it sounds now like the inside he
made not Napa sap more serious where
what this is way is it the first thought
that comes to my mind is how exciting is
it to arrive in Napa knowing that you
are the up-and-coming guy the guy who's
gonna know from when I got here was
bunch of bollocks strong what happened
you just was like it was almost took
Marin and just kind of just like it was
just it was just it was just [__] round
now just ferried around in that
circumstance so but if I see it then it
just looks like like I'm holding on to
stuff right when the truth is I'd rather
just not even talk about any of these
products ever but for some reason people
just really care about it and I can
never get to the fuuny Gritty of how I
feel about it without looking lack on
whinging about it or like a black
feeling some sort so long way another
I've heard some [__] things something to
me that quite similar to what you went
through and I think you can make your
peace with a situation but then describe
it
what happened without looking like a
dick I know I shouldn't even have to
look like a dick right you know I mean
you've got this you see your DNA there's
too many different kinds of people who
think what they think based on what they
have been told and where they got their
information and stop really I just think
it's all bollocks look really large just
if you really ask me what I've really
fooled by Islam listen
if I really sat down a broke it down for
you use some [__] somewhere all sorts
dude say I was there I was around them
times the reaction more than like the
actual story itself exactly it's like
it's just click me even now it's like
Disney talks about Nepal so I've liked
it so everyone just the same thing this
lad listen even if I told the proper
stories I'm was gonna twist up his lie
so a little bit pointless that feeling
well think about it how many times gonna
[__] talk about this thing and not
talk about it right so you just dance
around the issue a little bit no really
say problem and then [__] whoever
[__] TV politics goes around just
where were warning one of his rents
because he because he rants and talks
more yeah he's more from healing of
[__] stab wounds is usually the one
telling the [__] truth or like I mean
that's my experience it depends I know
guys the stab wounds were still do still
haven't told the full truth about the
album release you got you got just so
for those who don't know cuz like we've
got yeah right so we got a varied
audience so you Dom wasn't out but it
was finished it was ready to come out
you've gone up with some friends
so-called friends you get stabbed was a
six times
it was six yeah yeah and then you're in
a hospital denying that were pissed off
and on drugs and and pretty [__] up
yeah hmm yeah but he's even matter
because of who took me to hospital was
sorry friends with the guys who were
involved with it basically so yes I knew
them as well
it's just a mad situation just some of
the characters involved in it it's just
it's just it is worthy of another movie
is like you can't even explain it to
some people you just it just it's so
far-fetched which is where I bother
alright so without
what happened yeah what did you learn
from that experience generally don't get
stabbed
yes great if I actually don't get
stabbed in a Samba for [__] foreign
country do you never been to before when
you ever really got your people with him
around around how old were you when that
happened 1718 right you're going through
a [__] hell of a lot at that point
you're like creating a classic album
although you're not really aware if I
already did you know because looking
back now obviously with Clara in
hindsight you've got yeah I knew it's
gonna be an amazing album from day one
did you know what you're sitting on with
that album like were people it's not to
the fact we would still be talking about
like this today right yeah and just the
impact it had on people will no doubt
what I just put everything into it I
just I just I wanted to be a rapper so
bad I wanted to make like a rap album
like that wrap up which I loved and put
everything into it there's a time where
any kid could be easily distracted and I
give myself credit for being so
disciplined that forcing myself to call
studio because they don't those times
I'm from East London and the studio was
in South so when a huge distance really
was just fruit over half tunnel so your
engine in York Road it's easy to get
distracted as usual oh those times my
friends was tight with that time base
all drugs hard drugs he's that way you
went south to sort of get away from the
area now the studio was just in solder
right
would you come this year alone or would
you be with a lot of other people
sometimes I take them with me just but I
just come with me to my spot as they
were just about but never about all days
because they were shutters right why
they were rounding the thing that's the
thing I was saying about earlier one
with chaos I cuz who's around in the day
really that's amazing yeah but these
just so happened to be people that I
grew up with from young who just went a
bit further into what they shouldn't
have been doing which in turn made me
see for it was early and know there are
I don't like that yeah I don't care that
I don't care about that or just the
whole [__] that came with it
whatever the lion the the sneaking
people drop in each other and or
wherever even just seeing well addicts
for that lat properly laughs for the
first time like that really you'd seen
him around in your state or whatever a
drunks and we're addicts and all that
but just just had it coming up for the
Troy just just the whole everything
around it opened my eyes to like a world
that was always there but I didn't
really know that much about it it's all
like I was sitting next to it like kinda
coming up to the car asking for the bits
and order and I seen a lot rod Wow and
then see an hour behind the scenes how
much stress some of my friends were
having really like yeah you could buy
all these clothes and look around but
really just just headache so that's
that's what I saw made me not like all
this stress do you think because they're
people trying to rub them exactly
whatever getting arrested please this
dark iron child I never put a lot of
people don't a lot of people act like
Charles calling it and some people don't
have a good time in jail no my friends
at that point they made they made film
seemed cool that every summer they
disappeared lot of crowd called I'm
couldn't get older because they were
away light and it made me so he must
start thinking about missing out for a
little bit like I want to go film only
the truth isn't know it was also sort of
if everybody isn't as tough as they act
lap because you're going to prison
everyone's tough then how are you and
then it's a [__] jungle and
yeah and now a just almost the worst and
most approve your food is that fine for
some of these codes performative time in
your life as well though isn't it Lois
garland yeah
so that's not say with the discipline
like I just wanted to be in the studio
all the time and I'll being it's all at
6:00 in the morning I'll give I'll give
Wiley's credit for a lot like well he
was always around for that Wiley and Nic
Cage all these people sold out that
adapt that side of it now so we don't I
don't check for him think about as far
as my early career and how are we roll
together and all that that's that that's
yeah I know that's an important part of
my before you're miles ahead you're a
producer rapper your [__] miles own
on my own my own yeah I have my own son
before I enrolled deep and all down so a
lot of people I understand when they
talk about grab and order I finish some
people would have likely they think that
I've copied them that would be there
everyone a lot of people sound changed
when I came around are you changed again
for like rats over dope but that's it
it is way isn't it that's it's hard to
talk about about [__] do you do you
worry do you have does that bother you
or is it just that you get an
intermittent interview and we're more
bothered about the way that other people
more bother do but when I look at it I
was have to look outside of you yeah
well just John and I know he's Paul
McCartney Tyler being asked about John
Lennon look I don't know they was
talking over there about wanking with
him in the studios maybe maybe he's like
that's hot maybe that's our tidies of
being last to buy he's not to the point
we tell him yeah we had a wank go dude
anything else interview stopping story
have you got any stories like that
never me no stories or maybe you get in
the way you take the center view I've
never known and I've done 101 of these
podcasts I've never seen anyone get as
defensive is what your being and I'm not
so maybe kept themselves that's called
just give it a let's talk I'm just
saying like no being I can tell you've
been heavily criticized in the past and
then it's bothering you because and I
don't mean that in a in a currently way
because I'm a [__] funny and I'm
saying this as a made sort of thing is I
can feel how like [__] off you are but
with the way people talk about you at
this point after everything you've done
you probably feel a bit underappreciated
I'm guessing into again I step outside
of you but if we're having that
conversation we're gonna go through the
motions you want to rule me that's gonna
happen in him because again I can't see
as much as I want to say or I can but
then it takes up the whole interview
like it's just done right so I'll in but
like I said when I step outside of
myself I understand okay I see why
people want to know these things it's
the same with Tish lat yeah off the
finger on the roof like these crazy
teachers that yeah these are all stuff
all those things to me that I didn't
realize was a thing and to social media
got big that's not oh you're still
talking about that fry you like you care
about that okay well here's this what
happened and just what didn't happen
that but for some people's just
legendary stuff cause because again I'm
not I'm not looking at it like they are
it's just my life and also people are
looking for the sensation let's [__]
title and thumbnail and all that nobody
gave but so what I wonder it is after
hearing that story about you being
surrounded by drug dealin mate and and
say in the desperation just to play out
it no all my friends were and at your
point that's where there was a few
though that's who I was at that time
because they are an in a date did I
inspire any of your right in our own boy
in the corner and like yeah because I
saw more stuff that maybe I shouldn't
have seen mmm-hmm because of ours and
then some of you just through just
moving around London a bit more
when different people because because of
the music really awful let the music
took me around the country there was no
reason to go to Newcastle I never know
it knew anyone in Manchester or
Liverpool but that wasn't even a thing
it's not loud sometime like a lot
Caribbean people they might have family
in Manchester oh [__] no I didn't have
that so I wasn't a tours there at the
raves there's those experiences though
you can take them a number of ways like
those experience can also mess up some
people you know I mean what you saw
can have the opposite effect why do you
think it had it the formative effect
yeah maybe I maybe I was as a negative
effects on some stuff house or maybe
some stuff out the nd to see but you
just are just always that Oh at the end
of the day all it was that so I just
love just making music if I glad that's
it
I just always got on with it when you
were teaching yourself basically how to
write and to wrap where did all that
come from because obviously you write
your first rhyme and you're like alright
that's pretty fun like how did you go
from that to being able to write some of
the great stuff you ended up writing I
fit through listening so lat rap music
obviously and garage MCS and the jungle
emcees I think that they they have major
major influence on me because they would
have ting for as far as are concerned
they sound like we were what they
represented us gives us in your mind
UK mm-hmm yeah just or the hood whoever
but not just lat mark Maya who the way
wherever whoever was when a Council of
state and whoever was in the suburbs
you'd like to call to raves as long your
motivation doesn't didn't feel like it
was was money at that point it was it
was about respect was about a lot more
than that it felt anyway okay yes so
here's the second part so starting for
DJ but then when I started to jump on
the Mac you see you see the response
that the MCS were getting like these
times I was moving was storming storming
and he's kind of kind of cousins a da
so that's I kind of knew both of him
I see the response they used to get so I
wanted to be like him
I was just a DJ every now is to jump on
the mat for a joke and then it's the
youth clubs that you've club Col Charles
lat
loads of people you had to you had to
after energy if you've got an uh mic to
get people's attention and so that
becomes addicted to getting a response
so I think that's how I've got better
sort of that's that's why I never had
the two bars were never too crazy lyric
or they were kind of just quite smart
about catchy cuz the hook ease other
people could shot him and your voice is
totally different at anything else
anyway pretty much yeah yeah it's got
this weird like sort of yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's just a mad happy and excited
and it caught my attention like cuz it
was like nothing I've ever heard before
less and the American stuff and then
being like who's this guy but you know I
lacked people like Ghostface and loads
are the people that are like to where
people don't quite distinct got the
wrong sound than that yeah yeah even if
it wasn't as high pitched as my loud
like project Pat or Busta Rhymes
Ludacris all just different characters
you know it was a bad night in the night
music fifty of being gone back and forth
on Instagram it's no surprise anyone
that's not ever like good friends from
back in the day and yes usually fifty
there's nobody off-limits oh is that no
maybe
well you know I don't know maybe there's
some people who don't rap who maybe
wouldn't do that we've you know I mean
yeah I know
right onto are you doing boy in the
corner well what is it like then just
living the dream at that point you're
very young man being through these
experiences is that like golden sort of
the first feeling we're like [__] I've
made it ah I guess I'll still you know
just whatever just dealing with what
other stuff like whatever just hard
dealing with Fame well guess so that too
that live war I had it because it wasn't
at a point where it was with bouncing me
and all that yet it was it was it like
because it's a YouTube famous different
than mainstream film but like we you to
fame it's like no buckle will pass many
people in the street no one will [__]
nor me but the person who does is yes s
because it's cold
yeah because ten times yeah I could look
and see who would recognize me then yeah
that they they're probably know what
they for you know I am even though it's
probably some people who did largest a
certain demographic so an age age group
that would know yeah but everyone got to
that point lattice it went bonkers and
all that timeless tits anyone old people
in the old ladies were all did puzzle
mouth it's just my everyone I mean one
of the first times I went to know when I
started going to America
that's when he was mad I mean la
especially and the crazy thing off I
went to LA before nap on LA was the
first time I left England I went to con
shoot the fix I look sharp video in the
valley the kazoo did that was a I'm not
gonna forget what he did movies later I
did he made Zombieland
right
I need to sell some MTV programs we grew
up a block away I remember going there -
oh yeah I remember going to the shop and
seeing all the fitted hats on the wall
and buying everything I could I never
got America buying hats trainers and
dodgy track suits name is ruben
fleischer robbery exactly yeah yeah yeah
yeah doesn't look like he directed your
video but you did good job he did that
and stand up to a farmer was really cool
really cool and it's whether to see in
America and just understanding was a
totally different different being over
New York and LA are totally different as
well there's totally different type of
vibe that this the real the feeling in
the air everything is different the size
of the rows the food at this time was
just mad what I'm picking up from you at
that time is like a no point did you
pull your head out the water to breathe
like you were like I'm [__] like a
man on a mission sort of thing like I'm
not it's almost like you're scared this
sort of stop and admire what you've done
for fear of being like complacent
something yeah exactly
always yeah like yeah keep working under
the next song next that's why still not
yeah still not because I just noticed
the team goes in waves and I never I
never want to not be current or guests I
always want people to be enjoying my
music cuz I've not I've seen money now
to be feel so moneyed in different money
now different money now but it's just
yeah you could just you can buy more the
best part of it now is being able to
like really take care of people around
you like [__] what Health Care's like
good health care is expensive less stuff
stuff that really matters you know I
mean you can afford to do that that's
that that's the main stuff that's real
wealth is when someone's in trouble in
it and you can change this like that
yeah yeah I mean that's that's what it's
about the cars how many cars you and
upward like you can get them flash cars
whatever I've got a Ferrari with tints
on it so I don't even want to be seen so
what's the point anyway I mean that's
tough it doesn't matter if my musics
poppin and people like it that always
matters it that's why you get these
rappers that doesn't matter if Jay Z's
for whoever eight hundred mil deep and
all that when his album comes out
wants you to feel it yeah it's a good it
feels like a drug like too many ways
like a youtuber like you get a total
different style of entertainment but
like when people are loving what you're
doing there's a feeling that you get
that it's not about money it's not about
anything else it it like makes you feel
hall or something funny since I was a
kid yeah literally I was 14 when I was
on the texting her sort of that that's
this is what I do and a lot of MCS that
I've grown up we've they're doing it not
everyone from whoever gets to the double
whatever storm in a bunch of bunch of
people even people from another side of
the other side of town well even just
just different guys from all over who
kind of come up around and some are
sharp at different times but we've known
each other for long ladies like a like a
community yeah rappers and deejays and
emcees I could have said a lot more
names in it when you go back there sort
of the old places that you came from 100
you see the old faces what is it like as
you're a household name now you're not
you've gone beyond crime and everything
you've transcended it what is it like
how did he react to you now are you out
anyone say anything of it like now you
forgot where you came from or what
people used to like uses full out with
friends over stuff like that and people
that they'll say that I don't forget
where you can't like it and you remember
where you're from was that well we're
standing where I'm from where right now
and it's like what more do you want from
me yeah and it some people did just they
just say stuff to just say stuff and
it's like I'm not gonna react today
didn't want to fight do I want to fight
that well what what were you gonna do
this is just some snide comment and it's
something is usually some snide comment
so they can console someone they told a
set of snide comments young yeah
[Music]
has always been that way from having a
book a mentality of when someone tries
to get ha late themselves necessarily
crabs in the pocket there were some
people who ever maybe they just didn't
like you as much as you thought they lie
to you or maybe you just you felt away
about a certain way about them and they
didn't feel the same that maybe were
they were never really your mate like
that huh cuz coming up in a age when you
when you're from an area in the state
usually it's because you're powered in
together anyway so in a way here crabs
in the bucket but you just kind of hang
around by default in big groups so there
might be free of us but you could be
very different people within that 3 yeah
anyway so eventually everyone grows
outside this one fact that once girl or
she wasn't his girl by he thought he was
his girl or whatever their man is shot
in now or doing whatever he sank to him
he got him to rob him I just all sorts
of other this different [__] garland and
then just people just outgrow each other
last time yeah it was weird like maybe
that 10 years ago saying going back to
the area I'm a person even some people
cause they feel a way about me for
whatever reason is usually because they
ever seen me they're upset like I should
just be still be hangin outside the shop
society waiting for them or whatever
what do you think about the the idea
that rut was I shouldn't leave where
they're from it's because apparently
six-lane is like still living way grew
up and I was like do you think that's
silly do you think that's but even back
to my point it's lat
it's all good people saying that but
about the times I've gone home and I'm a
dude if I'm there I will chat to
everyone now cuz I've just wanted em
kids who just knew everyone I was in his
house their house there's outdo everyone
but the amount of people that I have you
seen finger now don't reach out to him
no more so I'll hang on a minute
oh you not hate each other like you
bugger you are sit with me because it
because I'll ever you can see man
let no come and you you [__] hate
each other you see tougher every day so
all that is a myth to me isn't it it's
the first time I've even talks about
that kind of thing now appreciate but
you are but you are supposed to move the
crazy finger okay know where we'll be
is that you come from a place like that
you move out to the suburbs and guess
what everyone from the suburbs is moving
it's a [__] bow and Hackney and it's
[__] Peckham and Latin it just can't
even afford to [__] play some [__]
strange to me like this yeah yeah yeah
this place on earth so and then so what
does it all mean
without [__] about ripping your ends
wrecking your money because you can't
ever you don't even like well how come
you look like it's not just come in and
just buy everything up didn't so what
what is it all mean it's just but
obviously I've been love for people you
grew up with to me I don't even feel
like I need to rip there's just that's
just natural to me as long I grew up
with you let that's that's especially
because I've just seen so much in the
world now where where I come from just
means so much to me so much different
people I might not be able to check for
them like I would because there's
hundreds of people to check for and and
I wouldn't be getting on my pay I know
loads of new people now as well in it
yeah all around the planet you can't
keep up with everyone all the time and
sometimes I've just got some [__] going
on where I want to be left the [__]
alone as well and get on with [__]
that's that's that's the way you're in
introspective like your thinker you do
you think I'll [__] long from your
music interviews right I did out loud it
could all have been over by now hmm if
at the end you heard some good decisions
about looks of it what was it like when
you first left London and sort of
realized that there were people was
boring Newcastle all right you went out
when I left that money I moved into
another half way outside
yes boring but I like talking about
going and doing shows
yes myself when you see a you start
seeing other people who you don't
necessarily make you didn't make that
music for them
you were the Newcastle crowed like
wicked bunch of white kids or yeah it's
like it's not your
you came from no no I'm from I'm from
bow also both bold light it's mixed
right so I'm for me I made maybe doubts
maybe maybe that's why maybe has to be
part of my music really I grew up with
white boys I grew up with Bengali
where's okay I'll go out with black
bears mainly that's the free different
ways to fight all the time but that's
just that's how it is territory
everyone's everyone's fight beside and
then you're cool again that's just
that's just the way is so when I said
when I don't think about yet laughter
loads of white people will have my music
in England then I remember oh
England's full of white people you made
the decision to like I don't know if it
was a conscious thing but your music
changed a lot you you and did different
styles but the ones that really took off
with oars like like dance for me young
guys or was that a conscious decision
very yeah yeah more conscious to some
people when if I feel some people really
genuinely thought that the label made me
do that
yeah and it's like at that point I
wasn't with so it was the end of end of
my record deal end of the term with
Excel so our Santa exercise for a free
album record deal I did all free they
all went gold and they were happy and
then I met Calvin Harris uh first of all
and I liked I liked in the 80s all those
chains and I met I said y'all I love
what you do man you're like sign light
out and then I said we should do
something and I think he was a bit
surprised so I tried a few things and
eventually he sent me the know actually
put the lyrics on a groove armada B they
sent me a beat I wrote the lyrics mm me
on a groove armada beat and then faint
mob well cuz me and uh Calvin when
contacting cage hiccup crazy man I hit
up carving I said y'all got these lyrics
but fitna might be a bit too good for
this beat so could you come up with
something like
in a rude way just didn't fit so he um
he sent over the thoughts of me P and I
remember having it this when I lived and
then I'll be like oh my god this this is
C because our life funky kind of style
music I couldn't make it
mm-hmm a lot of huayna corner as that
was just my attempt at making [__] I
couldn't make because I had immediate
sounds like well I'll do this then and
it works is so funny
and then um so do you did you know this
is a classic like bang straight why do
you know it was a clap I just knew that
I couldn't turn it off and that's
usually a good sign
laughs kept listening to the beat cat
listen to me then I must have recorded
it but the reason I did it a lot like
yeah I want to make pop music or
something more catchy happy you have to
think from playing a corner maybe just a
bit before and a bit after I was like
dark times I know everyone looks at it
like it was that some cool people had a
city's best work but it went really a
lot the greatest time for me personally
it's like when people talk about oasis
and their first album like they were
probably gone through hell when they
were hurt up but like is that the motion
is what people love yeah I don't know
what kind of life I was why I've been a
bit different from this now we're
talking about forgiving quiet yeah yeah
now you're in a good space you want to
make me that reflection yeah because I
feel like that that is that's wicked
does it suit that's that's serious
letting us to be able to do that it's
not I know some people look down on pop
music by is like it's not necessarily
easy to make a good pop song a big one
appeals to everyone
yeah especially when you've come off the
back of doing what I've done which was
free very really respectable under
grandi that bita crossover appeal
rap albums I guess that was that was at
the time some of it was a bit too weird
for some rap fans or even Graham fans at
the time were playing a corner
was it everybody's cup of tea like like
the way everyone talks about at night
but not everyone was feeling lighter so
and the factor by their not been touring
with Justin Timberlake L wasn't it was
just a lap dancer first that was not
Coco's wanted in places anyway when he
brought me on the willingness will.i.am
Justin Timberlake so I've been exposed
to all this by now and I'm sure by
they're not short support you're glad
red Chili Peppers before they yeah I've
heard someone message us about that yeah
never worth yeah massive mmm yeah so
I've been exposed to these big crowds
and all that stars laugh I thought it
was natural I wonder if it yeah the
crazy fingers that label wars with at
the time they weren't up for nap or they
wondered like Dizzee Rascal like this is
who you are and I mean my had and then
the other friend was a the main thing is
that they were after my door was not
renew I think they were trying to offer
me the same money
yeah and I'm I hope that we've all been
I should have more well yeah you've
established yourself no you knows that
feeling of almost like people around you
who should be caring for you
constricting what you want to do and use
and then you sort of want to branch out
and they're like now why don't you just
stay you know but you know what it may
protect in his brand or maybe you yeah
couldn't picture that or maybe wherever
I were it wasn't would have been good
for you minutes as shorts to his hipster
mates no more wait we're not in your
ever you know I mean just wherever those
policies I don't know in it I just know
that I'm not lacking the monies being
offered as that is and is where I'm not
a bidding war again but other labels or
interest to know that so I got to the
point war doesn't mean look like
anyone's got off of me you know more
money they're not really free English
tune and then I thought option took that
do it independent that I said I like the
sound of that
it's like yeah let's do that in just the
challenge of like let's do it
independent because it really I started
off like that white labels start off
with dumplings getting into DJ's like
slim Zee macton Marcus nasty few offers
and then white labels you go to the
record shops at the time say like River
division
couple of difference all across London
and then you'd have to give it to them
and wait for the money back and if and I
was widowed when I was doing like the
really early crime instrumentals that
whole going strings and all was a bunch
of other stuff that I remember and again
this was Wiley and all that as well and
wrote the notes people doing it and uh
and in yeah you've got to a point where
the cheapest cost I becoming so popular
we could go there with our own tunes
while he died VCS key sound I have my
own finger out there as well and they'll
just give up the money upfront give them
to files and pressed records they give
us wherever a few grand and we're good
so I'm sorry is going back to that but
on a bigger scale so that's why I was
happy so to go independent your tried
and tested you sell records now this is
not even yeah from dissing it but what
this is lat 2008 where that happened and
I was selling records like that you're
talking about in 2002 as a kid really so
through that I could not say the money
at the same time you're doing stuff like
pirate radio and that sort of thing
exactly when you play we've got our buzz
on pirate from pirate radio and in raves
and all doubt the Sidewinders and uh if
you want earlier than that because I
feel that Sidewinder was like the last
thing I feel like the first grammar is
the people different I remember young
man stand did and Rumble they were the
ones that I remember and it would have
been a few others in different parts of
London so that South London would have
had their raves
well Saffy's would have had their a
Southwest would have had their graves
because everything was a bit more
especially in that time everyone was a
lot people were beefing so it was a bit
sticky sometimes to go time I didn't
West without there she no first without
there she had no flooding out there she
stood out this year at about in
something like Rumble Stampede will
bring eastern north together a time when
Eastern North to areas in particular
we're really going at it
so Rumble Stampede was to raise that
became one and there's some there's some
early footage of that I don't know if
this footage of media is only for each
other so and then and then the
Sidewinders and that came later that's
when it was a national thing so
first time you guards are Milton kings
that's what do you serve it at Milton
Keynes dangerous place well it is when
you've got a bunch of where Bob Berman a
Manchester Liverpool gangsters yeah but
they come to have a good time yeah so
you talk about like some of these shows
where people would like that off gunshot
in the air and [__] like that ah yeah
yeah yeah like that's still pretty crazy
though to anyone from the outside who's
gonna [__] the guns in the first place
yeah by its let but there's been times
we've been there people have been
murdered mm-hmm and you have to deal
with that I guess if I even always
knowing that off what was that about
why is he did I don't know what he did I
don't know just what just happened
didn't come if it is you just you just
did and it has happened mm-hmm that's
sort of it got that like American early
nineties five that you've you've kind of
experience the different era of music to
what you really should have done from
when you like because that isn't normal
anymore really as it no I don't think
this is violent in the raves necessarily
Lordan brave got any way they look 110
years ago probably in a little revival
yes I mean they would have been gone for
that reason but it's I'm gonna values
just shut down because of gentrification
because everyone's moving back into
London I mean there's the space the
properties or whatever else I don't know
I've just been working in it so when you
so when you're me in these pop records
you talk about money
was there a part of that I'm motivator
for you where you like all right I want
to I'm saying Justin and Pharrell in
people like that around me making
serious [__] money
I believe I wasn't that it was just like
I wanna do it
earn arena and a stadium uh-huh it was
it wasn't the money cuz I don't feel
often feel like I could ever match their
money what they were getting at that
time and then look I turned down money
to do it by myself right without knowing
that they'd even the label that I've
been with for at least five six years
now
didn't have confidence in what I was
doing something then really was proving
your point that you could be your
breakout star of that world then and
push yourself into means nod no even
breakout star of that world just my
lattice okay let me just do this but I'm
not taking that money and it is time
remember I look up to jay-z Master P you
know diesel mogul that did that well it
feels like jay-z when you look a
reasonable doubt and then like all the
directions he took it in and going and
doing crazy and love get none of the
criticism that you've been subjected to
to me like as it may be where he's from
maybe yeah yeah this guy's everyone has
got NIF and that's why I know you say no
sometimes it feels like I'm getting
defensive that it feels that you get a
more [__] or than people like Jersey it
would because you're not sitting in
Brooklyn yeah or over there in the
miracle if you weren't an American
purist near your sickness in you want
another reasonable though same [__] and
and every other artists I see one one
Punk is the broker she was a punk she
was in the punk scene and she had a
massive tune thought finger that don't
feel Siouxsie Sioux or someone and then
everyone was on to her yeah he's just
the way it is but we're not step but
obviously when I'm dealing with it I've
[__] you in it so everyone that's our
fuel I've seen you kick off a few days
yeah but dead but then I'm a dude who
sits on watching documentaries a lot
says now oh oh it's not just oh it's not
just me it's not personal that that's
what people do and then I sit now oh
[__] I really really do lap Snoop Dogg's
old old songs these old albums that's
the way it is no I hate Snoop Dogg and
he's a [__] a [__] can sell out for
[__] doing that song never seems to
get a lot of [__] because he's too good
also people get emotionally attached to
these artists and feel like they like
Eminem yeah that album like so the
Marshall Mathers LP what about defined
an era and people hold on and they were
like I want to freeze you in time and I
want you to always be this guy and just
and he's definitely winning do you think
that they do like the UN law in the
corner the same way yes some people do
but then depends what you tuned in to
lat
it was almost better before social media
because last said half the stuff that
people talk about that I didn't know
thats how do you feel I was just getting
on with her making the music I didn't
even know when the corner was still a
thing
that sounds crazy in it yeah I think
it's all the way in the corner show when
I wasn't social would let people kids
away in a corner boy in the corner where
it was until I started getting on the
instagrams and the Twitter's and all
that which was only a few years ago yeah
Latino that was still a thing how did
you feel when you found out I was not
positive part me a bit joy about other
pies not half saying that now I
appreciate the real like I want you to
tell us the truth are you fully yeah
yeah because part of me I'm trying to
compare this to if I made a good video
whatever it's like yeah but what about
all the new stuff you made as well is it
this is an evolution of you as an artist
in in your mind you're probably better
now than you've ever been I would
imagine rap because you've gone through
all this experience you've worked with
all these girl artists hanging all this
extra so like is that a frustration with
your funds a little bit it is why I
always have to step up side of it I
don't want to sound like a [__] as well
I've learned sometimes you saw so it
doesn't matter book use a gold no such
fingers all for exposure so far just
rather not look like a [__] because I
like my interactions with people when
they come up to me in the street they've
got lactase it's it's easy as blessed
because they just lap my music there's
not too much finger me being a prep
everywhere so I choose try watchtower
saying I respect where you soon
so dance for me cause massive yeah your
life must have changed like that must
happy and did you you weren't really
aware of what was happened in the first
time were you more aware of this because
it's a blow up again didn't it took you
another level were you more aware of
that but you know what's good about
you're so positive
nice lanes people that I feel like that
album was my favorite hmm
for how my laugh went hmm was that the
memories that you have put in the album
out with everything just enjoyment or
even just a faceless enjoyment
everything got everything just got
better
everything was just nice our Dada Chee
out at the chief Lac peace offering yeah
I'm happiness now after all the dark
stuff that after the maneuver and that
and not to like not worries me loads
people go through dark stuff as well but
I mean don't have to do with it under
scrutiny in the public eye as well yeah
you grew up in a public way didn't it
pretty much yeah I'm still lucky to at
least I grew up normal before it in a
way you know in a way I was told I was
too I was still very popular from when I
was 16 I guess but I wasn't famous so I
know I know
whoever the [__] board of Bordeaux
all over the bathroom
we're just we're normal stuff no I mean
it does seem like you have them like
quite a healthy way of dealing with
things like self-doubt or negativity in
your life and it seems like you had that
quite early on maybe through your music
and things like that do you have you
ever been food because the question I
was going to ask you and you were
talking about dance with me and things
like that is did you worry about how it
would be received
you don't seem to doubt yourself too
much no idea I wasn't worried about I
receive again because it's still before
social media was your trainer honey it
hot like I think you live for that don't
you yeah I like [__] I think people some
people they don't know and understand
laughter I'm just into so much different
kinds of music I like funk I like so on
but I couldn't make a beat like that
right because I'm not a classically
trained carving has complained you can
sit there and play anything yeah I can't
do that what was it like watching him
for the first time in action were you
but I never mean our first two songs
even a song we've even bonkers we've
never been in a studio is it gets any
yeah know what Sonya so I've never even
seen him work didn't you I'm sure I
heard
like you were on a private jet with him
or once yeah he's private jet movies
initials I mean what was that
but in a few private jets of you yeah
your first experience of that like level
of life was it that level before no an
atom first time I got on a private jet
was I think it was around those times
though yeah gimme was having a 250th
birthday celebration are in Dublin
they sent me a private jet to get there
and that was that what I think to be
invited to yeah yeah yeah again still
not understanding like the levels of
your lateral we're getting about right
this is private jet laughs then we've
been on a few of them because sometimes
it makes it easier because if you've got
places a few places to be here it makes
it easier to get around all day yes it's
just nice having your people in there
that you don't have to queue up and push
it when you're working with like so like
you were supporting Justin Timberlake
and we're carving and and surrounded by
all these guys like what did you take
from like because these are different
artists different experiences what were
you absorbent from all of that just a
dad just they just that make a setup
mmm that still don't feel like I've
reached yet now my team still quite
small Rama's only now with Island
Records now as well so you've got that
machine behind you in that as well about
never - laughs Justin Timberlake on tour
is a lack of operation or about Chili
Peppers on toys on operation even
prodigy or tours younger as well how
many people do you think they are
working with them at least on Jordan it
yeah like it's a movement that they got
from place to place and loads people
different jobs but probably aside from
that and just seeing the big set ups and
how our show should be kind of patterned
and organized and these guys are pros
then hmm twist it's the top-end mm-hmm
but they need also hard last they were
I've never been on top of anyone know as
an [__] and every single one of them
was nice I remember I'll add a nice
trail of Chili Peppers were to us really
yeah Justin simply super nice FF one of
what everyone's been nice Rob yeah
the show is everyone here everyone
prodigy super cool when everyone was
just cool you weren't on Pharrell's
podcast hmm what what's he like is he's
an interest and dude I think like always
like you know he's one of these apart
into a bunch of bunch of times you known
him for a few years but he's like you
just never like up in in the studio of a
weird one
so we backed up I was in Miami and he
said I come to the studio man reason
he's working with this girl economy what
her name was
you know mayhem we could I think we get
some some kind of synergy going that's
that's what he said so I went to the
studio yeah he's introduced me to her
and he said you have a code as I went
and recorded the verse that it came out
was for all he's gone where is he you
have to go sorry cool can I can I have
to cook coconut the seed in our now we
can't give you the immunity okay I give
you the music where we have to speak to
throw so I just [__] this record this
[__] you're not gonna let me have my
musical it's not me
but then afterward late years later I
understand the are because we're at
things get leaked and all that and guess
what happened you've got leads right it
wasn't you ever I wasn't a sort of mad
guy good we can't let you have this yeah
I've met him a few times it's been kind
of just cool but snotlout we've had
black loads a big conversation or
nothing like that
chat the other day and he's cause well
as you say there's anyone you did have
that kind of like artistic relationship
with apart from people like Calvin is
there anyone you've really clicked with
like in musically know lots of people
without roads layer obviously carve Ian
I really got a Robin Williams went to
his house in LA chatted to him that's
why it justice respect him was lousy
he's a pro isn't he come on man look at
the levels man and people some people
even with that they had the cheek to
that what are you doing a Jew role is
that oh we used to do that eighty
million power rocker dude and he's
[__] one of the biggest artists in
ever
British history Emma and he wants to do
really that was a good the first time
around he wanted me to be on rude box
alright it's time he hit me I wasn't
ready for it then and then I did that
one no okay look I'm with prodigies with
Liam that I've like I talked to no
Gallagher never were to view by love now
text away about decent leave okay
actually get on with most people if one
is anyone I don't get them with I just
kind of just stay away that's quite a
collaboration though isn't it like being
able to just oh I'm a van he'll Italy
talking before conversations with you it
must be interesting because you you seem
to have quite an appreciation for a lot
of different styles and music mmm what's
what are you listening to and it are you
listening to a lot of other people's
music or is it like your ass I like a
lot the drill stuff I was like rap music
I always listen to be listening to rap
music by the other day I don't know what
made me do it but I just five listening
to Kraftwerk again right like that's old
school as well yeah and that's it as
well because I understand about music
walk through creating and being if so
much now understand the raw how far
ahead word day here and then I listen to
a bit of ARF noise the first hour which
I've never heard and then listen to was
like wow this sounds like these guys
were sampling back then that's what this
is it sounds all weird a little kind of
arty or whatever but they're just
sampling that's what it sounds like at
first time I think was the first album
and then I started listening to go Gary
Numan sorry I sit here in my car if it
must have come up on the Spotify
McCarran emo yeah you made that here in
my car and listen to drove around listen
to it's like yeah it's just sit and then
just let it roll and a bunch of these
other stuff come on nah it's good innit
yeah
this sounds futuristic now this sounds
like what 2018 should sound like
laughing Black Rock how I hit this is
not fair sight more to fit he is old now
really in it
how far ahead is he and then in the tune
come on
basement jaxx samples that oh yeah like
rowdy did he did this last it's managed
just shows you again how part classic
music just just lives
one thing I was interested you've see
you've done like Red Hot Chili Peppers
Justin Timberlake oh that's a crazy list
of people how do you build up a
relationship with the crowd for all
these different kinds of people and what
are you looking for how you feel in
before you're going out at a concert
like are you looking to go out there and
make eye contact with people or just
place the crowd or what yeah both for
trying sometimes a bit awkward beginning
you don't wait to see my icons I kind of
just feel out the crowd and I'll never
stay in one place because I started off
like that you just be doing early I'm
still here I realize you can't just you
move around a lot no yeah just the
stages have gotten bigger we fish right
right but every night in your own little
one last dozen used to be some off-key
thing you just you just do it just just
play it as much as you can and then oh
yeah I just give the crowd stuff to do
and just record remember it's for them I
learned early about just rapping at the
crowd tonight that's not the one and I'm
not James for me to just be rapping at
you interaction oh yeah yeah we're here
together
taxi so when when you've blown up to
that degree now like obviously the
money's coming in a different level than
ever before did you get like hangers-on
coming out of nowhere that ever happen
to you or yeah happens when you go to
lout willing we still go to like the
Western clubs and that you just find
people that live there professional with
just plotting themselves next to you and
before you know it oh yeah just like
that should make it actually I like that
they're just about it just happens you
crowd and ladies later loud where do I
know you from a good I can't I don't
know how I know you hear that that
happens in here but you can you get
taken in by anyone like that are you
good at judging the situation of like
all right this guy's you keep their moms
and really like West and not much so I
eventually just kind of fizzled out at
that point then so you're going off in
that direction grime is still on its own
path and you're you're sort of watching
especially in the last few years some of
these big grime artist sort of birth in
the all talking about boy in the corner
all fur like was a storm she said that
like that was his first big album that
he listened to what is it like knowing
that you sort of were the beginning for
all of this it's crazy to me I don't
know something I don't know how to take
it yeah it's just it's a case of okay
yeah I'm glad I'm telling it but some of
me it's just me like that
oh and good people around me some good
decisions obviously but it something's
just like luck now well just born at the
right time came up in the right tired
and right era that just about it too
much - yeah
like it seems that you just sort of want
to live it I feel I feel like if I did
all that I really accepted that I'll be
a bit more of an [__] all the stuff
you've been telling me I'd be onto every
day reminding everyone yes Tom's he
gives them Brit Awards I'll just be
reminded people by everything I've done
and all doubt constantly and sometimes I
wonder if someone's trying it like not
actually this is what happened this what
about you like I said you might owe him
that prick over there never got the
message so you would be there all day
and I really I should be living laughs
making experiences and making music
gotta listen to your new EP which is out
right now
London link in the description below for
everyone watching it seems like it's
like not quite full circle bong there's
a you're coming back to your roots a bit
is that I mean is that a conscious
decision I've made beats again yeah so
that that's that's about as close to my
roots as you're gonna get that's that's
that is the same as playing a corner
yeah well one of the one of the feats I
was like this could be on boy in the
corner like normally I think it was that
one yeah yeah it just had that sound
like so people are like a fan of that
version of you they probably love that
but like you did a track was kept
it just feels you start one it feels
darker this Alden like you know but
you're not going through that anymore is
what's the reason what's the thinking
behind this album we just one not just
one is the king he was mainly about the
beats though as well started making
beats again got unable and learn how to
use it even though my manager was trying
to tell me to the over ten years ago and
I wasn't listening but sometimes when
you pick things up for yourself you you
do it so I did it that's so much fun
recording it doing it and working with
all these people that call that finger
heart wanna make a tune yeah come down
and really it comes the years like that
a lot of the time and I love that that
so that's how he was was he came even
would be money now you come studio let's
get it done and I love I love hard a
workman all him even worse kept table
skips up here money - also we've
recorded the thing they're just divvy I
love that and if there's a bunch of
songs that didn't make it onto that EP
because there's only five trucks right
he's fat eating yeah but but them tracks
are still good but will sound better in
another format these five tracks and a
good to Gary so nice
I wouldn't escape the tomb which he
produced himself it's a nicer house
thought what's the word it's just
showcases my own a few of my different
production stars and gas me which I'd
say is more like a kind of almost Gary G
baseline kind of poll six days kind of
Skippy one and then you've got the one
that said this from the P money which is
called spin your as like bark original
Graham yeah for me when I was on pirate
radio making beats for other MCS people
to spit on and then your quality which
might be my favorite because that's a
sample from an old hard course on by buy
a new key song cool sound of music and
if you see that if the the EP album
cover that would have been around the
time that original song came out and I
was into PI radio and that jungle know
that then so for me to sample doubtful
lack almost full cycle to behave in a
position to do it and make it work
that's a childhood song for me that's
one of the first songs that I heard of
that type of style of music that made me
love jungle and all that you know I mean
and to sample it do justice he said oh
it's okay I've got his blessing and to
me and again just for the for that older
generation let me know I do respect my
elders in this I respect all the scenes
that came before me especially in
British me British music you know I mean
if you know a little obvious link to
Jamaican or that's world one
I love hardcore love drama bass jungle
wall it out so that was a nice that
saluted him and then you got a pattern
of as one again is just another like
just happy feel-good song with a little
bit of a garage II kind of feel to it it
feels like like a little bit like cut
what Kanye did recently just drop in
like like corn for quality like and not
just like alright this is do you know
what when the videos look at he's man a
lazy day with their seven Tunes man
[__] just drop their lazy and in a
magic number or something you remembered
it yeah say what is interesting right
the so what got you back into making
your own beats was that it can't just be
your manager being like try this do you
know I said I was 10 years ago and I did
so just I just I thought oh I just
picked it up you get your fingers were
you like we look back into that no I'd
you know what cuz I tried it maybe two
years ago right there's been a few times
I've tried it and just didn't care they
still like it and it was just always
easier to like by by this plant I've had
so much songs if I'm a big producers in
order it was easy to get beats from
people but I think with the last hour
we're asking
I feel like I'd like you could only go
chase bigger producers get trials more
money and give them be given more
runaround thanks that was like one of me
favorites that you've done for sure back
to just a straight rap yeah at a time
where I feel like there's a lot of
singing music ah yes I knew I was gonna
gets the great I knew they probably
wouldn't be as popular as lat big
because I knew about the N a flat the
big obvious hits on it there's a big
sing alongs but if like you know
Eminem's didn't cover cause he exactly
reminded as a rat House Rock & Roll
album you know what I mean history we
like we let me know and I'll keep saying
a rap rap Memphis rallyin yeah and then
I guess this sounds kind of the same in
a way but I brought back that the kind
of dance element but me making it so
with my own little twisted little swag
on it there's something quite satisfying
when you listen back and you can hear
like those little production quirks you
know I mean those things that you almost
feel like a signature like the way a
beats down all the way things are lined
up back to ya know I'm just interested
to know cuz like you know when we were
talking about like the kanye album
jay-z's albums and how you can hear
those little bits that they've done
themselves I can almost be like that
beat that even just like a little high
hat or something like that is Kanye's do
you feel like you have you know at the
know sometimes I've got teams of people
make you feel like you have signatures
like that where people listen back and
you feel like I'll put this in and
people know that was my little nah cuz
even with people who hear this cuz
they're cause you got will say for cuz I
said that the money rats get to make so
if it's all about the other four they're
so different from each other there's
almost like a region in a way even for
myself listening back to them blah blah
I made that it's kind of encouraging for
me again yeah because I I started off
making beats because I couldn't get
beats from nobody mm-hmm so it's nice
again I've come full circle again and
I'm gonna keep going there's some stuff
that didn't make it there I'll see okay
what else can I make and I might get
bored agin it what was it like early on
I was interesting when you said you were
making beats for other people
what's it like because obviously with
rap
music alongside oh you're such a good
rapper what's it like when you hear a
rapper say to you
you're a good producer because there's
something quite satisfying that you're
making something they want to put their
voice to I almost kill more about
hearings or someone smash it on one of
my beats know when I hear Peter up that
looks like yeah yeah that's as a
producer I feel like that's that's so
fulfilling
mm-hmm I made the sanding and then once
he's done it working and editing it
around him and in the same ways he came
because I will see came I was looking
like ah I want to put a female one here
I don't know who so we literally sat
there looking on YouTube that order best
female Spears around the UK tour the
most popular ones and obviously they all
good they've all got their their day of
I have their wave some more popular
lovers not even necessarily because
they're better rappers so I'm on a time
I just cuz of women it just the way they
have promote themselves is better but
when I heard see Kane she was on the
toddler TV show and the way she was
rapping just reminded me of like I said
on the roof back in the day Dejan that
sounds like okay she grew up to that
she's embodied that spirit this that's
the kind of spit are a need on this beat
especially if you were leaving an
attempt to go after P money because
anything he touches this is flawless
it's a flawless delivery it's flawless
wordplay just it's just as well but yes
he's gonna bid on it in a YouTube
football yeah do you that because some
producers are quite not bossy but like
um what's the what's the dr. Dre
documentary there's on defiant one else
you know there's a lot of talk about how
dr. dre gives feedback to all the
rappers or makes them better rappers are
you that kind of producer you the kind
of guy who lets someone come and do that
flow and then you'll fit it back like
what's your relationship are you also
and so I've gotta go somewhere else
you see where I said about our
understood now I couldn't have to be
mm-hmm
now understand that why I left right I
did the same feel if them came back but
but I'll leave them to it because if
they have em see me P money CK in the
type of MCS no doubt that we are okay no
get so ever wear the type of way where
if we in a room to give up where we come
from is everyone stood Merck everyone
wants to be like go hard sometimes
that's not the rat energy or tone for a
song
so that competitiveness you mean you
want to rather than against each other
no I've seen like the mood of a song if
I'm in there and you just want to show
how wicked you are and all that or I
might be the same I might just overdo it
because where ever gets is in the room
and know what's the he needs to know I'm
a spit RN feels the same way but that
beat might not have needed that much
energy or yes be that loud and rowdy
like still true for example like Snoop
Dogg is not try and do Rock Hill Dre on
there is he's just try and do you say
I'm saying that so just so there's some
tile just leave the room just let them
give people space and no even just some
time not even just because of odd people
trying to murder each other which
sometimes people need room to get get it
wrong if you're reading from if you just
written the lyrics and your reader from
then you're gonna make mistakes and and
if people in there you can't be
comfortable making those mistakes and it
just messes with your noise especially
got dizzy Roscoe sitting opposite you
know but I'm saying I'm the same last
right someone's did it doesn't matter
who it is I might not I might not wanna
I want to want you to hear the finished
product so just like locusts that
respect to leave for an hour hour and a
half comeback is it done yeah yes I feel
that same way with videos sometimes like
I feel like it sometimes you can be
making a video and then someone looks in
and goes I would do this and you but I
know no yeah like you want to have that
we've we've just launched a channel
together I didn't let you see the
trailer until the day it launched which
was
[__] stressful maybe [__] himself
and I was [__] myself because up
until the day when I showed him that
another editor had been doing it and I
was just like I don't know what we're
gonna do about this but I sat down for
like two hours and you were in the pub
drinking you came back and I remember
the smile you had on your face when you
walked in the room you're like that's
that's exactly what we wanted yeah but
it takes time to get to that point
doesn't it do you have you like what's
your vibe when you're in a studio do you
work with other people and throw lyrics
off them or are you just completely just
like I'm writing this down man getting
in there and doing it you sometimes like
they might write near bars first and you
know they're not me but in other times
slapped on a song with Frisco and the
double I wrote the first my first verse
then wrote a hook off the back of that
and in Frisco come and roll off the back
of that so so you bounce off each other
that's why I like working
we'vewe've with all rappers you sound
incredibly flexible to be honest like
you sound like it's the fun of the the
process still it's not always just about
my ego and order lyrically you'll hear
that obviously I'm writing myself in my
lyrics but that's what rappers do we
talk ourselves up in it
but as far as just understanding anyone
who comes in that I've picked him to
work with them for a reason and they've
taken time out of did whatever they're
doing to come as well I mean we never
met before so it's respect at the end of
the day it has to yes to you and then
place we're coming for lot of us are
coming from respect means a lot respect
is West where are some people ain't here
no more
yeah before you start an album are you
starting out with a vision or you let's
use like let's just get in there and
sometimes I'll just jump in because I'll
just jump in sometimes don't start as an
album uh-huh I say it does to myself to
jump in the studio but sometime I start
as a tune like that'sthat's that spin
your dad that beat I had that beat
around the time I made rescue hmm and if
I keep saying you should do just do sign
without but I just didn't have anything
mm-hmm
maybe it took for me to go and get in
the studio with someone like PD money
who just automatically knows exactly
what to do with that be he's got the
energy to fire that's what he wants in
it for me to do maybe like my own space
where just couldn't just weren't feeling
it I don't always
my own beats enough to jump on them now
I've got folders of beats that I've made
that I just I don't know what's upon it
mmm The Hunger sims they could still
layer within you though like us in some
people they get to a certain point where
it just feels like they feel like
they've completed it and yeah the reason
to keep on making music isn't there as
much some people felt that way with
jay-z for a little while didn't they
they felt like he was just yeah when he
did that for if for yeah I think even
before that I remember a lot of people I
see it's not the same he's like damn
rich he's that he's doing all this extra
stuff Beyonce's his life I could still
give you silent Arab are obvious about
that as far as the kind of energy you
want for a rapper like jay-z if you
heard from from the beginning is what's
your so Mia what's your personal life
being like another custom I don't really
know a lot about you as a block behind
the scenes you keep seem to keep things
that a deliberate thing yeah because you
need to keep something for your select
look look how much of them miss some of
the stuff that people think they know
look at that
twisted and thinking your stories and
all that again some other stuff you just
have to just keep it in this social
media world you manage that though
that's impressive to be fair you must
have tried hard for that yes I found
that social media I just do it for show
people I've got music art and then keep
it up didn't you once sir get this is a
total random question by then you once
get plugged in the trying to chat kim
kardashian or something like yeah
captain yeah I just want some water
samples there actually yeah was it was
just a wall to everyone some Australian
cuz it are trying to cheat me up to go
and check out Kim Kardashian and I was
trying to say profits know that it's not
gonna work
I'll go on my do not a [__] I yeah I
kind of always just go up so you just
stop bullying me I went over there sat
bad we were and it just went it went
black if we was gonna go but worse you
don't say yeah yeah that's what you
don't say is that do you know that
firsthand now or is that is that what
you said that's Holly wasn't really just
just like I said it you could have never
had done the whole thing that guy over
there says that I can't chat you up sort
of vibe no I just automatically said all
right I would give a lot the bill to say
I try to check him Kardashian field
that's that's actually like the failure
that's the key bit yeah yeah yeah try
how you see your ranking car - I think I
should be a load no questions from your
funds and funds of the podcast I [__] me
some of these coke these are my
questions for the records thoughts on
mumble rap that some of you yeah yeah
I'm not putting all mumbling nothing I
think they're from regions that you've
got no kind of reference right for so it
sounds like in 1 billion but I like I
lacked I've always lacked southern rap
mmhmm yeah I heard that think that was
an inspiration for you by age 86 mafia
yeah I'd like 360 office and Master P
and orders cash money so what if
festival festival performer mmm I used
to love big they are in Australia
they're not doing any more glass Therese
always blood what was it like doing best
to me that was pretty which time yeah
complained about the fact that they
haven't asked you to headline yet after
all the mean you're the guy over up over
here like yeah sure they could they
could have headlined me I could have
headlined a couple times so especially
where no one where they at the the
gorillas fill in for me no feeling for
the headline on and yes i yeah like the
gorillas records oh okay yeah me
laughing is who is gonna believe this
these people just all over the place
like like festivals in it yeah that's
what I do that's what I've been doing
make it hard for whoever's coming and
after that's that's that's what I've
done all those festivals especially but
so olas it was arc I never complained I
said I could I can headline is and
everyone took it is like well who do you
think you are right that's like you know
the [__] I am you cheeky like this this
is not new are you new here because this
is what I've been doing
yeah even to the point where they've got
to jump through hoops for guys so now
just do what a one lat there's a point
of these big festivals they made me play
with a patent because they couldn't get
in their head like how can you your hat
man in the DJ make where fifty sixty
thousand people go mad for our hour and
twenty minutes or whatever yeah so did
that yeah get away the tune stuff
doesn't sound as good with live
instruments about cool okay tiny we done
it now yeah cool can you [__] off now
which is cool let me get back to what I
was doing and get back to the original
sound if I had to sand off or to use the
band
Agosto they kind of said they won't pay
me so yeah any kind of food I'm not
forcing it the food the first the whoa
nah man I don't know how many times one
class to me what a lot of five so these
are not it was to my class timber used
about our festivals live read in and
just whatever I repeat
festivals where they just haven't seen
the vision and then eventually they are
they get when I saw this plan - about
the main stage right because I've been
doing weather from the beginning from
2003 - and for in some of the tents and
smaller stages but when I got to that
main stage level that's that's when they
all out oh this is risky because there
was no one else there were no big you
came wrapped dude on the main stage they
just knew how big it was so you had to
put in here but they just couldn't see
doing that so after I found that smash
tear then not just do I want that yeah
that's it
I booked someone booked you and then go
because there because they were festival
of people with bands all or loads going
on on the stage so I are gay like that's
all they used to
yeah and it's their money sorry I'll get
down as well let's take these nothing's
that when I say no not like [__] me
and not upset about it I've got to grow
a bit an experience to understand why
people do the things they do in it yet
next one are the two questions that are
like basically opposite perspective some
I'm so putting this - you tell him I
like Gerard daily but he don't belong on
there not his best music get back the
holiday bongos dance with me oh yeah
they've got me on they've got the Skepta
song on there and that let's begin at
the low with what point of mockery that
person's come along yeah wait basically
he's he wants the pop songs we've got
another guy who said mmm the opposite
which is why did he turn his back on
crime yeah you see do you see people say
that yeah did you see in my heart year
last week near pricks
right laughing their [__] okay even
talked about some people talk about like
I'm like like I'm their long-lost bad
that just left them or something
what are you [__] talking about
language these are really flew about
some try and like Tony Tolliver I think
your tickets because what I even mean
what turn my back on Graham do you
actually even know what [__] up and
you give a [__] made album and
smashed it and started going around the
world and taurine and doing interviews
and doing stuff that that's what happens
when you use everyone you know John
wrong
no you stay involved you just go you
just you just got the job yeah so then I
did that fifteen years ago so but by now
you're talking about are grams reached
America lion you celebrate in an hour
you're pissed off that I did it back
then they're not turning my back on that
which one is it yeah that's that's my
argument over there why are you [__]
talking about now I appreciate that
yeah where do you see the future of the
UK scene headed like hopefully closer to
our Frances because France of ways at
60% French music by law on French radio
and even even the way there Spotify is
set up it benefits French artists and
French rappers I'm sure and I remember a
French rock I salute the soul El Sol
every day so loud that's that's way but
that's that's over there that's like
saying like what gets like Rodney P your
site India it's been so many big Rodney
people obviously but there's been so
much after that yeah I mean and in
France has got at least probably at
least six stadium rappers or
Stadium Latorre none of those dude I
work to have oral son
I was just on his album they did a
stadium tour when was that
March all around France stadiums in
about 20 20 20 venues stud the France
and I know that the France because
that's where I supported red Chili
Peppers and then he just announced
another one
nah I know so I know him I know Bluebird
us stadiums and there's a bunch of
others they're just that big and we
still aren't there yet really not really
even know arenas not yeah and maybe
laughs Danny
yeah but not consistently life I put and
I don't know if it would be an arena
tour my name is big enough but I don't
know if they're saying hey a deafening
standard Eminem versus MJ kid did you
hear em GK's response what did he hear
father of was quite a funny I thought
was I was decent right buffet I thought
you made some kind of good points and
that I think especially that last first
I thought was like you really went after
and then the thing he said about your 40
talking about you're gonna get
trick-trick
and all that yeah that was funny and
even you should have cut to me I'm sick
I thought was like like he's sort of you
come at it from a good angle I thought
like I respect what you are but I'm not
having this like he did respect him he
wasn't cause he's he's tied it we should
decide about his daughter saying it's
like if if you've got a daughter I don't
know I think I think what he said was
she's hot it wasn't it was kinda
disrespectful but it wasn't like I don't
think that's all he did is that it
they're saying but you know what okay
good for them do you think people that I
feel everyone's so wet these days man
nah oh my god finish this thing did you
see what he said it's like some [__]
playground [__] - lad he dissed him you
still think this figures like they have
no [__] to our conversation about
that this next question yeah what's your
current situation with Wiley obviously I
don't know the last time you tweeted was
like I'm gonna [__] kill you [__] like
that I'm gonna [__] kill you I said
one day you're gonna push me too far and
I'm gonna kill you right there's a
difference yeah is there anything
happened since then like in terms of the
relationship I thought it from there
there is no relationship that's what
people just kind of get around there's
no relationship you lot made this feud
live for years I'll just would have
minded my business and you keep bringing
up the same [__] [__] then he goes
and Ivy's Dom rants and then you then
end winning in the papers this far the
feud the few to be he look where
everything beef man just shut the [__]
up
how about that's how I feel in Italy oh
you caught that beef everyone calls it
be four fuses bonus I'm tired of asking
you ask me something those people people
love drama basically yeah they don't
love drama when it comes to their
thoughts tip yes I love other people's
like comedy it's funny when it just
don't give a [__] biggest influences so
you got any favorite like our loads
boxes dialogues I love boxing
[Music]
darn a popular spot I think of any like
people you've really looked up there was
it as a kid like sort of things they
weren't robbers when I was younger I
really looked up to Daniel shooting he
was a footballer mm-hmm but no place for
a play on
Nigerian yes oh yeah he like as far as
we looked at to him cause he was from my
area as far as I my local and then Wow
Bruce Lee just yeah
fair one did a what do you think the
talent shows like x-factor everything's
great place everything's got because
what expects are just kind of replaced
stars in their eyes you know in it back
in the day it stars in her eyes just so
much better than x-factor no one on
stars in their eyes ever cries that's
what's good about stars in their eyes
you go on man you get to just put a wig
on and be like someone else for 20
minutes hmm
some people are stuck in that thing for
like two years after x-factor there's be
terrible
mmm horrible life for those people who
do you [__] me this is a world one who
do you think killed biggie impact
there's too much mix up my I knew it
yeah so that's a tough one man I've
heard I've heard different of different
versions but there was rock
ice Robbie Williams about you but I can
email them saying like you got anything
that you think would be good like bring
up oil use like I can't think of
anything right now but there is one
little thing that dizzy used to get a
little bit of flack for Illuminati
symbolism and pictures or something like
that like did all that actually happen
yeah it was a little pier there was a
little phase where some people they just
couldn't understand I worked really hard
and it happened to me so they have just
good Dave just full-out to ever be
signed up yeah because the boy Anna
Kournikova with and I think at the time
if you actually see if we will talk
about 50 different shots yeah yeah and
that's the one that was made I feel I'll
just playin up but not no definitely sir
but I remember being in a restaurant my
food actually come up to me I sat down
and a Stein asking me you know what was
that about like what like what did you
really sign up with the lumini you know
start talking about trying to eat my
curry go in his talking about this and
human artists are some people they
really brought in today and believe they
just feel like I don't understand that I
put in mad hours in the studio laps or
six seven in the morning for the record
if the Illuminati want to approach me
and make me rich um I'm happy with that
we can make that happen people don't
know loud are evil all confused where
you talk about the Freemasons or what
not what even is it I don't know is done
cuz there's this one yeah the Freemasons
yeah yeah if it were for music where do
you think you'd be right now um I can't
even I've never really wanted to do
anything other than now maybe athletics
when I was younger I really I like run
in an earthy sandbox maybe I thought
think so laughs enough to just hang in
there with with a good box are about
what they I really have to put
themselves through out laughs I don't
want that for my life yeah
one of the last ones what advice would
you give yourself at 16 years old if you
could generally or out with it that
everything has led me to this point
we're sitting around with this big table
just yeah just having a ladder is worst
things to be doing was it Friday Friday
afternoon yeah we could be stuck in
office in it last question from Mimi how
would you like to be remembered forever
good one sighs I like that I really
appreciate you coming on I took so long
that means a lot I appreciate it Thanks
if everyone wants to check there's new
wave payoff but the link in the
description below you can buy that on
itunes of you ask me it's all happening
if you like the video I'll hit the like
button subscribe thanks for watching
we'll see as Leah [__] off